>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Anne McLean: Good evening.
I'm Anne McLean from the
Library's Music Division.
This is a great crowd.
Thank you for coming.
We are really pleased to be able
to have such a wonderful group
of people here for this talk
centering on Peter Guralnick's book,
Sam Phillips, The Man Who
Invented Rock and Roll.
And I say centering on
because we're fortunate tonight
to be presenting not only one but
two astute and perceptive observers
of popular music culture.
Peter has invited Geoffrey Himes
for what should be a
deeply informed conversation
of very wide musical horizons.
We're really pleased to have
Peter here making a stop
on a packed nationwide
book tour for a book
that the New York Times calls
beautiful and meticulous.
It's the story of recording
producer, Sam Phillips,
as rock and roll prophet.
That's a description
from the journalist,
Gregory Cott [assumed spelling],
who calls Phillips a key architect
in a musical as well
as social revolution.
Peter's the offer of a number
of poetic and provocative
and insightful books that
chronicle our nation's pop history.
These include benchmark studies on
Elvis Presley, Last Train to Memphis
and Careless Love, and
the powerful Dream Boogie,
The Triumph of Sam Cooke.
We're also pleased to have the
chance to welcome Geoffrey Himes,
author of a major book on Bruce
Springsteen, Born in the USA,
and a long time feature
commentator for the Washington Post.
If you follow magazines like
Rolling Stone, Paste, Down Beat
and Jazz Times, you'll know the
calliber of his thought and writing.
This lecture is part of a huge and
diverse 90th anniversary season.
I know some of you've
been to our events.
We hope you'll come back
for more evenings like this.
Check out our brochure.
I'd like to say that the Library's
Music Division is the home
of the world's largest music
collection, 22 million items.
But we not only have the artifacts,
but we love creating programs
like this that introduce
not only those artifacts
of our magnificent shared musical
culture but give us a chance
to think about one
of the only things
that can transcend all cultural
boundaries, the love of great music.
So thanks so much.
Please welcome Peter
Guralnick and Geoffrey Himes.
[ Applause ]
>> Geoffrey Himes: All right.
Hello. All right.
Thanks for coming everybody.
I'm glad to see so
many people coming out.
What I want to talk about
first is when we talk
about popular music history, we
usually think of it being made
by people who sing
and play instruments.
But I think one of the
things that's interesting
about Peter's new book is
how he points out the fact
that non musicians play an important
part in shaping the history
of popular music, and I was hoping
that we could start off
having you talk a bit
about why non musicians are an
important part of this history.
>> Peter Guralnick:
Well I think Sam --
Sam actually would have [inaudible]
the title producer didn't exist
at the time, but he liked
to think of himself more
as a practicing psychologist.
But his mission in some
ways was very different
from let's say the mission
of somebody like Rick Hall
who also very much influenced
recorded music, all kinds of people.
Willie Mitchell created the
sound that showcased Al Green,
very different from the Albert
Greene with an E on the end
who had debuted with Back Up Train.
Am I feeding back [inaudible]?
Speak up a little?
All right.
I'm going to shout out.
Somebody like Rick Hall was
looking to create a sound.
He had a sound mind.
You could go through any number
of takes to create that sound.
Sam was looking for the
sound that was in you.
Sam was looking to bring out of you
what you may or may not know was
in yourself and to
give you confidence
and courage to express it.
And in many ways, it's funny, I may
have mentioned that in the book,
but I was thinking the
other day that I could just
as easily have called the
book I Hear America Sing,
The Emergence of Sam Phillips.
I mean, that's what it is.
He heard America singing.
He heard America singing
[inaudible] birds on the trees
or could be the wind
out in the country.
It could be the silence
of the country evening.
It was that kind of singing --
it was what DeFord Bailey heard that
inspired him to play the harmonica.
Listened to the sounds of trains.
Living out in the country.
DeFord Bailey was the person who
was the first African American
and for many years the only African
American in the Grand Ole Opry,
wonderful harmonica player.
So in some ways, Sam was
the exception, I think,
to what Geoffrey is talking about.
Producers like Chips Moman
played a very active role in --
not in inflicting the will but in
looking for something in particular.
And that is what Sam was --
if you listen to a sampling --
I mean I put together a
collection with the same title
as the book on Yep Roc Records.
You can get it on vinyl,
three LP's and two CD's.
But it -- for those vinyl
favor -- those who favor vinyl.
But he had such a range of music.
The one thing that ties
it together is spontaneity
and individuality of performing.
That's what he was looking for
most of all and sort of like
when you talk about Harmonica Frank,
a sort of a medicine show performer
who played the harmonica
and when he came
to sing just moved the
harmonica around his mouth.
He didn't use a bracket
or anything like that.
And to Sam, Harmonica
Frank was a beautiful hobo,
and he said, "You're a hobo.
You have to be inspired.
You have to be resourceful."
And that's what he
looked for in music.
So I don't know if
that's a direct response
to what Geoffrey said,
but it's my response.
>> Geoffrey Himes: But the book,
you talk about all these
profound records that came
out during these 11 years that
Sam was actively making records.
Whether it's Howlin' Wolf or
Elvis Presley or Jerry Lee Lewis
or Charlie Rich or Ike Turner,
these are all obviously very
talented people, but it seems to be
in the book you're
making the argument
that the music they
made was different
because Sam Phillips
was a collaborator.
Is that accurate to say?
Is that fair to say?
>> Peter Guralnick: You
sound so much better
than I do on the microphone.
I don't know.
We'll see if the fault is
in the mic or if it's in me.
I suspect it's in me.
But -- okay.
See, that's what I needed.
I needed coaching.
But it's -- I forget
where we were in this.
>> Geoffrey Himes: What
difference did it make
that Sam was a collaborator?
>> Peter Guralnick: I
think so much of it.
I don't think Sam knew what
was in each of these artists.
He saw them as artists.
He saw them as people who
he sensed -- he believed --
one of the things Sam believed
in most strongly was his
ability to read people.
It was also his ears.
Those were probably the two
things he prided himself most on.
But he didn't know
necessarily what each person --
in the case of Howlin'
Wolf, he knew what he heard.
It's where the soul
of man never dies.
In that case, he might as well have
been Alan Lomax or field reporter
because although what he was trying
to do was to bring out the sound
of Howlin' Wolf to the maximum
degree that you would be able
to appreciate it as
he appreciated it
on a record as opposed to in person.
There, he was simply
trying to record it.
But when he met Elvis
Presley, he describes him
as being the most introspective
person whoever came into his studio
and one of the most insecure.
And all he simply recognized
the unique talent.
He didn't know what that talent was.
In that case, his genius if you want
to call it that, was the patience,
and the man not giving to patience
as his associate assistant
[inaudible] the man not given
to patience.
Sam showed the most extraordinary
patience, and he was willing to wait
until he heard emerge this
voice and then he wanted
to do everything he
could to assist it.
But it wasn't like he had
a vision for Elvis Presley.
He just simply -- or that he had
a vision for Little Junior Parker.
I mean, he was looking for them
to express themselves in a way
that he sensed they had -- they
were able to express themselves.
In the case of somebody
like Johnny Cash,
I think what Geoffrey says is
certainly true in the sense
that Johnny Cash came in with
[inaudible] blues and recorded it
at one of his very first sessions
in what amounted to a demo.
And he's got this kind
of [inaudible] voice
that you would never
recognize as Johnny Cash.
He sounds almost like
Marty Robbins singing
in a higher range than he used to.
And Sam just didn't
hear the song at all.
Eventually, he came to see the song.
Sam came to see the song
as a metaphor for the way
in which we're all in prison,
which is kind of a funny thing.
Sam was not a poetic person
necessarily, but that was --
and he sold that to
Johnny -- to John --
Johnny Cash as being a way in which
the songs communicated to everybody
and then he got John to
speed up the tempo much
against Johnny Cash's will and
as he did with I Walk the Line,
and Johnny Cash said,
"This will never work.
I'll do it, but we'll
never use it," and walked
out of the studio convinced
they would never use it.
When he heard it on the radio,
he said, "Dang, that's good."
>> Geoffrey Himes: Right, but what
I'm saying is that just as Elvis
and Johnny Cash didn't have a clear
vision of what they were going to do
and just as Sam didn't have a clear
vision of what they were going
to do, but it was the fact
that they were working together
that made a difference.
They were like both on an
artistic qwest together,
and neither of them
would have achieved it
without the other in a sense.
>> Peter Guralnick: Yeah.
I guess that's true.
But the thing was is that Sam
was looking for spontaneity.
I remember.
Sam was looking for
spontaneity above all.
I mean, Jack Kerouac talked
about spontaneous [inaudible].
That was Sam.
And it was nurturing spontaneity
and seizing upon the feeling
as opposed to the perfection.
I mean, Sam hated the
word perfection.
He said, "I hate that word.
It should be banned from
the English language."
I think what he meant
was that as you seek --
as you correct all your mistakes,
as you make everything perfect
you achieve nothing more
than kind of sterility.
And so, yeah, he was working with
artists who in almost every case
from Howlin' Wolf, Mike
Turner to Jerry Lee Lewis,
Charlie Rich apprised that
same kind of spontaneity.
And that was what he
nurtured most of all I think.
But it was not so much that
he had a template or any kind
of specific approach that would
-- and it just delighted him.
I mean, for instance,
Harmonica Frank or you listen --
you probably didn't hear it
coming in, but he listened
to Joe Hill Louis,
and you think, "God,
how could anybody ever record it?"
I mean, it's completely out of tune.
It's -- Sam loved distortion.
You go right to the edge of
distortion and over the edge.
And yet there's something about
it that's absolutely both unique
and compelling.
And that was what drew Sam
to the music to begi with,
and I think it's what he tried to
bring out of each of the musicians.
He didn't want them settling down.
>> Geoffrey Himes: One of the things
you talked about in the book is
that Sam had this -- did have a
vision in the sense that he grew
up among poor people in Alabama
who were not paid attention to by
and large by the cultural
establishment of the 40's.
And he was convinced that these
poor southerners both black
and white had something to say
and needed a catalyst or vehicle
to have it come out, to have it
emerge into the public marketplace
so to speak and that was
what he was going to do.
You write about this.
Even though he didn't have
a specific sonic template
for these people, he did
have that as a mission.
Is that right?
>> Peter Guralnick:
Well, he did, yeah.
But I mean, the thing is is that Sam
and from the age of seven or eight,
he said to me -- he
said, "Listen to me now."
I'm talking about an
8 or 9-year-old kid.
Had a sense of racial
injustice, was struck by the fact.
He was working in the fields on 323
acre farm that his father rented
and lost with the depression.
He was working with black
and white sharecroppers.
And it struck him so forcibly.
And I know this from relatives
of Sam's of his generation
who it definitely did not strike
as forcibly and were not thrilled
to hear this little kid starting off
his opinions about racial injustice.
I mean, Sam would talk
about anything.
He was not at risk
of being accepted.
He wasn't -- to his benefit
and to his disbenefit too.
But he -- and from a very
early age if not from 8 or 9,
certainly from his
teens on he believed
that the African American music --
he wanted to give voice
to the voiceless.
This was his mission all the
way through as Geoffrey said it.
It became his mission for
poor whites as well as blacks,
but to begin with, the
idea was that his idea was
that the African American
expression both secular
and gospel what he heard
coming out of the black church,
which was a block and a half
from the church he attended
and that he would stand outside
of every afternoon for as long
as he could in the summer.
He said with the windows open
wide he could fully partake
of the service.
When we went back to it in 1999,
I've never seen anyone
more thrilled going
into that African American church.
But that -- sounds he heard in
the fields and what he observed
on Beale Street when he
was 16, his first vision
of Beale Street was a vision of
freedom and set him in his mind
that he was going to move -- he was
going to live in Memphis some day,
not live in Memphis to
work in the Hotel Peabody,
which his what he did do.
It was to be -- to live in
Memphis which was exemplified
by Beale Street, black
America's mainstream.
So he -- but he believed
that ever fiber of his being
from a very early age, let's
say from early teens on,
that if a mainstream audience
meaning a white audience could ever
hear the sounds he had heard
the African American sounds
that they would be swept away
by the power of that music
and spirituality of that music.
Not just the music, but the
message and that this would break
down the walls of segregation,
which is more a dream then it is --
but that was why he opened his
first studio or his only studio.
He opened the studio -- the
Memphis Recording Service
at 706 Union Avenue
January 2, 1950 on the cusp
of the second half
of the 20th century.
But that's when he opened it.
I mean, he said it
contemporaneously was to give some
of these great Negro artists in
the south the opportunity to record
where they don't have any.
And that's what he did for
the first four or five years
that the studio was open, and he did
it on his belief, not out of his --
he did it at great economic peril
to himself, at great risk to himself
in many ways, but he did it
because he believed so strongly
that once the world was exposed,
once the mainstream
audience was exposed
that they would seize
upon this music and that
that would open up doors.
It would break down the
walls of segregation in a way
that wasn't going to change
every element of society.
It was going to change
a large element
of the way that people thought.
>> Geoffrey Himes: What I found
striking reading the book,
especially about this sense of
mission that Sam had was that a lot
of the artists that he worked
with were striving towards something
similar, but it didn't seem
like they could articulate it or
be as conscious of it as Sam was.
One of the things that
marked Sam was that --
as you say, even at 8 or 9 --
he could articulate and
consciously set these kind of goals,
which strikes me and makes --
just one of the things that
makes him an unusual person.
>> Peter Guralnick: I mean, his
first ambition was to be a great --
was to be a -- not great -- criminal
defense lawyer like Clarence Darrow
to right the wrongs of society,
which were both social and had to do
with both social and racial justice.
That was -- and he wasn't able
to do that because he had to drop
out of school after his junior
year because his father died.
But, I mean, an example of the
way in which Geoffrey's talking
about is he often spoke about how he
didn't know anyone who was more free
of prejudice than Elvis Presley.
He believed there was
no question whatsoever
that Elvis shared his goal --
knew exactly what he was doing.
I believe this too.
I mean, but I didn't know Elvis.
I wrote him a letter, but
that's as close as I got.
But he said that he believed
that Elvis just as much
as he knew exactly what they were
doing, knew that they were sneaking
around the race line,
knew what he was doing
when he embraced not just
African American music
but African American artists when
he had his picture in the paper
with BB King, Little Junior Parker,
Bobby Blue Bland when he spoke
about his admiration of these
African American artists
in the mainstream press.
And when he was hailed as what
was then called a race hero
in the African American
press at that time.
Something which was set aside
-- I mean, not set aside by him
but it was reversed
and later [inaudible]
within the African
American community.
But Sam said there was no question
that Elvis shared those views,
that he knew what they were doing.
He knew that -- and that he
gloried in the idea that --
he says, "You got to admit,"
he says, "I just got to say,
didn't we knock the shit
out of that race line?"
But Elvis was not saying it.
Elvis was not going to articulate
it and probably none of his artists.
I mean, someone like Jerry Lee Lewis
-- I'm not going to get into --
I'm not going to imagine
the complexity
of Jerry Lee Lewis' feelings about
anything because it could go --
sort of like trying to imagine
Merle Haggard's political views.
I mean, these are brilliant
musicians,
and these are real geniuses.
But anyway -- but the point is
that when Jerry Lee Lewis says
if I could play guitar like
BB King, I'd be president --
to get to Jerry Lee Lewis.
BB King was -- the fact that
Sam had recorded not just Elvis
but BB King was a key element
in bringing him in the studio.
>> Geoffrey Himes: One of the
things that the book points out is
that Sam Phillips worked with a lot
of different people besides Elvis
and the Million Dollar Quartet,
but the relationship between Elvis
and Sam is very interesting.
You're talking about how they
shared these kind of values.
At the same time, they
were different people.
I was wondering if you could
articulate what the differences
and how those differences
complimented and allowed them
to make the records they made.
>> Peter Guralnick: Well,
to say one thing about Sam.
The Sam who recorded these
great records from Rocket 88
and Howlin' Wolf right on
through to Charlie Rich's
Who will the Next Fool Be was not
-- Sam in the studio is not the same
who created the public persona
that many of you have seen
from his later years which
was a conscious creation
which was very different and
which was highly articulate,
highly oratorical, high
ecclesiastical at times
or at least I wrote
about meeting him.
He was like an old testament prophet
sauntering from the hill top.
But that was not the
person who did the music.
The person who produced
the music for want
of a better word was
someone who nurtured it,
who was very soft spoken but
who was firm in his beliefs
and who was never going
to back down about --
on anything that he did believe.
As he said, he was not going to
get up on any tall stumps to try
to convince either preachers
or DJ's or record distributors
to play his music because
he knew these people.
They were friends.
And he knew that their views
were not necessarily his.
But he was certainly going to
try to sell what he believed
in in the best way that he knew how.
And he had this degree of
certainty of self-certainty.
I think that's probably the thing
that set him most apart from someone
like Elvis who in a
certain sense if you were
to say what was Elvis' problem?
I mean, it was -- aside
from what might be called --
and again, I'm as reluctant to
assign a term to this as I am
to describe the -- Merle
Haggard's politics.
I mean, you could call what Elvis
suffered from the last five years
of his life as a kind
of clinical depression,
which was just never dealt with.
But the other thing was, his
biggest problem was simply
that unlike someone like Sam Cooke
who absorbed everything he could
from everyone that he
met and then moved on,
Elvis was someone who
wanted to be loved.
And it was -- as Sam
described him --
had the insecurity that
prevented him from saying okay,
I've gotten what I can from you,
from Sam, from Colonel Parker,
from whoever and moved on to do
what he himself wanted to do.
And it was sort of an
inability to deal with --
for want of a better
word -- adulthood.
And so I think that
that's -- that's where --
I mean, Sam was on a mission.
He knew what he wanted to do.
He set out to do it.
He was somebody who suffered
from depression all his life.
He had -- twice he had eight
electroshock treatments
when he was -- 1944 --
when he was 21 years old
and electroshock was not -- it
was at the dawn of electric.
What's it called now?
Electroconvulsive -- yeah,
electroconvulsive therapy, yeah.
And this is a very different thing
from the kind of shock treatment
that he had, and many people
never recovered from it.
But this is what Sam believed at 21.
He's settled on the idea that
this was what he needed to happen.
He did it at this sanitarium
in Birmingham.
And then right after Rocket
88 -- and he would tell --
I mean, if you met him on the
street, he might tell you this.
If Geoffrey were interviewing
him, he would --
Geoffrey might ask him about
Elvis, and he might say,
"Let me tell you about
the electroshock."
Because he believed
there was no shame in it
and that mental illness was no
different then physical illness
and that one shouldn't hide anything
and that he wasn't proud
of having recovered.
It's like talking about
a recovering alcoholic.
He saw it as this was
his temperament
and this was how he dealt with it.
He was fortunate, and he was
not going to try to hide it.
But the point is went after
the second set in '51 right
after Rocket 88 he
was told by the doctor
who administered the electroshock
that he would never be able
to lead a normal life or
that he would be unlikely
to be able to avoid excitement.
And the next thing he did was
he recorded Howlin' Wolf a few
weeks later.
>> Geoffrey Himes: You've
mentioned several times
that this is your most personal
book, and there's more of you
in this book then there
are in previous books.
For those who don't know, Peter has
written several works of fiction,
and his first sort of major trilogy
was collected pieces, Lost Highway,
Feel like Going Home and Sweet
Soul Music and then the sort
of second trilogy of biographies
which is a two volume Elvis Presley
biography and Sam Cooke and now Sam.
Why was this the most personal book?
Was it merely just because you knew
Sam better than these other subjects
or was it something -- I mean, I
think there's something in this book
where he talked about
how Sam articulated --
the reason you devoted
your life to music.
>> Peter Guralnick: Well, yeah.
I think actually Sam's vision
of art in many ways corresponded
to my own -- his vision -- he got
a book as a prize, I Dare You,
by the founder of Ralston
Purina whose name is --
his son or grandson was
the Senator from Missouri.
Danforth, yeah, yeah.
And that was the theme of
his life was you had to dare.
You had to overcome
your inhibitions.
You had to overcome your fears.
In many respects, the thing that was
so inspiring to me about meeting Sam
for the first time in
'79 was not so much
that he revealed something
I never thought of is
that he validated everything
that I had ever believed.
And he validated it within a
large philosophical concept
and in a sense placed the
music that had so influenced me
but which was not necessarily
related to the ideas,
placed the music within
this philosophical
and almost revolutionary
context that he just --
I was just thrilled to have this.
And even I was running a boys camp
at the time, did for many years,
and all the principles that Sam
spoke, trying to [inaudible]
and articulate in running his
recording ventures were the same
principles that I was
trying to carry out.
I'm not saying I achieved
them to the same extent,
but I think that this thing
about being personal is
that you'll find a lot of me in the
first three books I wrote in Feel
Like Going Home, Lost
Highway and Sweet Soul Music.
But I rigorously kept
myself out of the Elvis
and the Sam Cooke biography.
I felt like I didn't want to --
I wanted to tell this in a way
that allowed the story
itself to come out.
I think if you read that -- if you
saw what I put in, what I left out,
you could draw a portrait of me
from those books that would be
as accurate as from anything else.
I mean, I think there's
no such thing
as Sam said he hated perfection.
Well, I mean, I don't
-- I'll raise him one.
I'll say there's no such
thing as objectivity.
And that this is a kind of myth
that people perpetuate in all kinds
of ways but everything comes
down to the angle of perception.
What you put in, what you leave out.
This says an enormous
amount about a painter,
about a musician, about a writer.
And so you could draw a portrait of
me from these books in which I --
rigorously eliminated
myself in a way
that I hadn't from
the earlier books.
This is the Sam Cooke and the Elvis.
But here, I knew from the beginning
that what I wanted to create
with the Sam Phillips was a book,
like a novel, a nonfiction novel
that did justice to the nonlinearity
of his life, the explosiveness
of his life and to the
variousness of human experience.
I wanted to right something that
was along the lines of what Sam saw
so that it could be
both epic and intimate.
It could be tragic and comic.
It could be discursive and focused.
It could be like -- I
mean, Sam always talked
about every session being like -- he
wanted every session to be like Gone
with the Wind and big fun too.
Now I'm not going to cite Gone with
the Wind, but it's like the idea
of an epic family novel
or something.
But the thing was that the only
way I could do this, I didn't --
Sam lived to a far riper
age than either Sam Cooke
who died at -- what did he die?
33, I think, and Elvis
who died at 42.
And the thing about Sam was he left
the music business more or less
in 1960 when he was 37 years old.
He lived to be 80.
And so I didn't want a book that
was a recitation of honors gained
or travels made or
critiques, praise given.
I wanted to do something that
did justice to the craziness
of Sam's life, not crazy
in the mental health way
but just the absolute individuality,
as Kerouac might have said,
the wowness of Sam's life.
And I wanted -- and the
only way I could do that was
by introducing myself not as a
character so much as a witness
because I knew him for 25 years.
And that was the way that I had
of breaking up the narrative.
It was a way I had of making it
more anecdotal, being able --
veering away from strict chronology
and being able to take a story
from beginning to end even
if the end happened years
after what the chronological
course of the narrative was.
And in the course of
it, I mean, I just --
as Sam said to me fairly early on
-- I mean, I met him in '79 and got
to know him much better when
I was working on the Elvis,
and we did a whole bunch
of interviews and stuff
and started going out to dinner.
But as Sam said to me, he
says, "You know, my son Knox --
Knox loved you from the
first, but I didn't."
So I could say that Sam believed
that you keep a distance
from people.
Otherwise, they're going
to push you off the cliff.
And Sam was kind enough to say,
"Well, I knew that you," he says,
"I had to keep my distance because I
knew you had your doubts about me,"
and I'm thinking, "I
had my doubts about you?
I was sold from the first word.
That's very nice of
you to say that."
So we sort of went
from this formal --
I mean, when I met him in '79
he had done, by his account,
that was the first interview
he ever had done outside
of the Memphis newspapers and the
trades, Billboard and Cash Box
and there were a couple of others.
He forget about a couple.
But in essence, that was true.
He did not want to do interviews.
He didn't believe -- he
didn't want to look back.
He saw interviews as looking back.
He always wanted to look forward.
He was in radio then.
But that first interview was
like the [inaudible] of Sam.
I mean, I didn't realize
what it was at the time.
It was an amazing experience,
and I met him in a flood.
The radio station had flooded.
He had this new radio
station he had just built,
just built every square inch of
it down to the plantings outside,
and the sprinkler system
let go the night before.
I had been trying to get
an interview for ten years,
and the sprinkler system let go.
And Knox, Sam's son, Knox, who
had been trying to sell Sam
on doing the interview, met me
in the parking lot and said,
"I don't think we can
do the interview.
We're going to have to postpone."
I'm thinking postpone?
Postpone? You know,
another ten years?
And so eventually being the
resourceful person that I am
and being so creative,
I said, "Well,
isn't there anything
I can do to help?"
A brilliant suggestion.
And so I carried buckets of water.
I squeegee'd.
I moved tapes and then
at the end of this eight
or nine hours we did
what turned out for me
to be the shortest
interview Sam ever did.
It was only 2.5 hours.
And I had no idea really
what it represented.
It was teachings of Sam and
in a sense after knowing him
for 25 years, I came to realize
how important his sense of mission,
his sense of teaching, of
conveying these lessons,
these life lessons was.
I couldn't have known that at the
time, but it was quite astonishing.
So I don't know what that was.
It wasn't friendship certainly.
I was there.
I recorded both his thoughts
and my reactions and wrote
about them in Lost Highway.
But then over the years, we
became friendlier or friendly
and then eventually I would
say after many years friends
and then one day he said,
"You know, I really love you."
And I said, "Wow, that's
really," but that was --
at that point, he wasn't
feeling well.
But it -- no, I mean,
it's hard to say.
I mean, Geoffrey's right.
It is in many ways the most
personal but in another way I was
so intensely bound up in the Sam
Cooke, and it expresses so many
of my views of society, of
race, of class, of the community
that nurtured Sam Cooke and
has been so important in terms
of my being afforded access
through the writing I'd
done, the people I met.
So -- but I guess I'd have
to say Sam feels this is
the most [inaudible] person.
Maybe I should be embarrassed
about that.
>> Geoffrey Himes: Obviously, the
Sam Phillips books cover a lot
of the same territory
as the Elvis piece did.
I just wondered if you could talk a
bit about why you wanted to return
to that territory to -- what you
thought to be gained by going back
with that same territory and also it
seems -- you may disagree with this,
but from my perspective,
it seems that both Elvis
and Sam had this burst of brilliant
triumps in the 50s, early 60s
and then had difficulty or were
quieter after life, but also seems
that they dealt with that
challenge in different ways.
I wonder if you could
speak to that as well.
>> Pete Guralnick:
That's a lot of things.
If I were to just disagree
wholesale,
that would be the easiest
way to answer.
But no, I don't disagree.
But in terms of second acts, I
mean, who except Philip Roth?
I mean, there are other people come
back and surpass the achievements
for which they were
hailed in their youth.
I mean, you look at so
many people in the arts.
After an intense period of early
creativity, what would have happened
to Sam Cooke had he lived?
I mean, I don't know.
I mean, you could postulate that he
would have been Mayor of Chicago,
but it's hard to know what --
I guess I didn't see it as
revisiting the same territory.
I mean, in some ways, having written
to Sam Cooke and thinking about
or having written a lot
about blues, you're thinking
about writing a biography
of Muddy Waters
which Robert Gordon did a
wonderful biography of Muddy Waters
or thinking about doing a
biography of Otis Redding.
That would have seen to
me like a repetition.
In Sam's case, he was
so [inaudible] generous.
I just never thought of him.
I mean, Elvis was part of the story.
But by no means, not even -- by no
means, the main part of the story.
And I guess I saw this as if it
was revisiting, it was revisited
in a completely different
perspective,
showing all of these things.
I mean, I've written
about Howlin' Wolf before.
This was in a completely
different perspective.
I mean, one of the
things, for example,
in writing about Howlin' Wolf in
this book was the discovery by --
and this is in the Howlin'
Wolf biography by Mark Hoffman
and his co-writer was
named somebody I'm sure.
Yeah, James Segrest, right.
And they found that Howlin' Wolf
had suffered this enormous nervous
breakdown in the Army and was
actually released in those terms
and released with the idea that
he would never again be able
to lead anything approaching
a normal life.
And although this was
something that neither --
Wolf had said to me one time, I
never read this, I never heard it --
but Wolf had said to me when I
asked about the Army thinking about,
that this must have been
an expansive experience,
getting him off the
farm, out of Mississippi.
I'm asking him.
I thought at that point because
he had said it sometimes found
[inaudible] which he never did.
He got as far as Tacoma or
state of Washington anyway.
But he -- I asked him about
it from that point of view.
He says, "Oh, man.
The Army, they drill
you so hard it just
about gave me a nervous breakdown."
Well, it did.
It gave him a literal
nervous breakdown,
and that's how he mustered
out of the Army.
And in this book -- I mean, I
considered it, and I thought, well,
geez, Sam -- neither Sam nor Wolf
knew about the other's experience
and yet there's no question
in my mind that this was one
of the ways in which they connected.
They were both extraordinarily
bright people,
extraordinarily observant people.
In Wolf's case, extraordinarily
paranoid person.
But just an amazimg person.
I mean, Sam said about Wolf about
the first time they met, he says,
"Well, as much as I was reading the
Wolf, he was reading me much more."
But that was a way
-- in other words,
for me that changed the
portrait completely.
Seeing Elvis come in, for example,
into the studio in the wake
of an article about The Prisonaires,
the quintet from the Tennessee State
Penitentiary that Sam had recorded
in the early summer of '53,
and there was a big article
in the Commercial -- or maybe it
was the Press Scimitar that talked
about this man, Sam Phillips, who
was looking for original talent,
was willing to record anybody,
and there's no question in my mind
that this is why Elvis came into
the studio a few weeks later.
But the point is seeing
it within that context,
that's something I wrote about to
some extent in the Elvis biography.
But it loomed so much larger
within this very different context.
So I guess from my point
of view, that was --
and I saw Sam also as
a person who even long
after he had left the field
for which he had gained --
in which he so changed the world
and as Jerry Wexler said in a decade
of recording he created a
millennium's worth of work.
But I saw him as being -- continuing
to be as interesting a person,
as challenging a person,
as individual a person,
and I wanted to continue
in the book to continue
to show the intrinsic interest of
this character, the adventurousness
of this person and the sense,
exploratoriness and also the sense
of insecurity that
continued to fuel him.
So it -- I guess from my point
of view if you do think of it
as revisiting or if I think of it
as revisiting, I wouldn't go back.
And there are many places
that I never have gone back
because I felt there
was no way to do it.
I do have to say, though, that
the one place I would always have
revisited and it's one of the
two biggest regrets of my life,
and this shows how
shallow a person I am.
One, that I no longer play baseball.
I played baseball until I was
48, and I just miss that so much.
I played -- I went back to tennis.
That's okay, but baseball --
but the other is that when I sent
Solomon Berg whom Geoffrey knew well
-- when I sent Solomon Berg
a copy of the Sam Cooke,
the next time I saw him, he
says, "You know, it's great Pete.
It's really great."
He says, "But when are
we going to do the book?"
And I tried so many
times we talked about it.
Solomon -- it was the one book
that I ever thought that I would do
in somebody else's voice.
I mean, and I tried
to get Solomon --
Solomon was someone
like quick silver.
It was hard to get him to commit.
And if he said, "Look,
why don't you fly
out to L.A., I'll buy the ticket.
I'll put you up.
I'll find you a Pied-a- terre,"
after first turning down the offer
of payment because you never
knew what that might mean --
it's not even a question
of being compromised.
It's a question of showing up at
the airport and having no ticket.
In fact, being sued for malfeasance.
But the other thing was I knew that
if I went out to L.A. I could fly
out to L.A. and find out
that Solomon was in Japan.
So I -- but I tried to
get him to commit to it,
and put down on tape what his
experiences were like when he was 8,
9, 10, when he was a
wonder boy preacher
in his grandmother's church.
And he says, "Okay, okay.
How about when I was 10?"
I said, "Okay, when you were 10.
Did something happen
when you were 10?"
This is about the funniest
and sad story.
So then he said, "That's when
they put me out on the street."
Well, I never heard
anything like that.
And so I said, "What do
you mean they put you --
who put you out on the street?"
He said, "That's what I
could never find out."
I said, "Why did they put
you out in the street?"
He says, "I don't know."
And he burst into tears, which was
the last three times I saw him.
Solomon, the most jolly, just one of
the most brilliant people, I mean,
just unbelievable but he gave way
to emotion each of
the last three times.
I don't know what it meant.
I don't know.
But that's the one place I would
revisit that a thousand times.
I would give anything to have been
able to have written that book
in Solomon's voice
and as Solomon says,
it would have been the
greatest book in the world.
>> Geoffrey Himes: Before we
throw it open to the audience,
I was wanting to ask
you one more thing.
We were talking at dinner about the
challenges and rewards of the kind
of life that we do,
writing about music.
And you were speaking earlier --
we were speaking earlier about
how Sam affirmed a lot of the --
articulated and affirmed a lot
of the motivations
you had in your work.
We also talked about how
non musicians do play a role
in shaping music, and I think that
we do too to a much smaller extent
than Sam Phillips perhaps
but a little bit.
>> Peter Guralnick: Are
you saying we should be
in the rock and roll Hall of Fame?
>> Geoffrey Himes: No, but --
>> Peter Guralnick:
No halls of fame.
>> Geoffrey Himes: But
I guess what I'm leading
up to is can you talk a
little bit about how --
why you embarked on this work
and what's kept you
at it all these years?
>> Peter Guralnick: You
mean the work in general?
Yeah. Right.
Well, I always wanted
to be a writer.
You know I always wanted
to be a baseball player.
But I wanted to be -- also I
always wanted to be a writer
from the time I was
6 or 7 years old.
My grandfather taught
English at [inaudible] School.
He was a great inspiration
to me, and I was surrounded
by books with my parents.
And I just -- but I
mean, it was nobody --
as Sam would say, it was
nobody's motivation but my own.
I wanted to be a writer.
And I published a collection
of short stories when I was 20.
I'd written my first
novel when I was 19.
It was not music at all that
-- I mean, I loved music.
But it was the blues.
I fell into the blues
when I was about 15 or 16.
And that just led me
to everything else.
But when I was around 20 or 21,
all of a sudden these
underground weekly sprang up,
Crawdaddy started up, and it was
this kid named Paul Williams.
He was a few years younger than I
was, and I knew him from the school
that he attended some
years after I did.
And anyway, in several instances,
people came to me and said,
you know, how would you -- Paul
came and said, "How would you
like to write for Crawdaddy?"
Or "How would you like to write for
[inaudible] something about music?"
Because everybody knew how
crazy I was about the blues.
And I said, "Great, then I
want to write about the blues."
And so there I am in early
issues of Crawdaddy writing
about Robert P. Williams with
Skip James, Buddy Guy in the midst
of Moby Grape, Jefferson
Airplane, Grateful Dead.
I mean -- and Psychodelian General.
I'm not putting that down.
I'm just saying it's an odd --
I mean, I don't belong
there but there I am.
And when this friend of mine named
Larry Stark [assumed spelling]
became the drama critic, the first
drama critic at Boston After Dark,
which was essentially started --
it was the Boston Phoenix
and that started
as a way to sell advertising.
I mean, it was just -- they needed
content to sell the advertising
for entertainment because
this guy who was
in Harvard Business School realized
the mainstream papers weren't
selling advertising for
concerts and stuff like that.
So Larry said, "How would
you like to write on music?"
And I said, "Yeah, sure.
But I want to write about
Muddy Waters, James Brown,
Bo Diddley, Howlin' Wolf."
And that's what I did.
My idea, the only reason I did it,
was to tell people about this music
that I knew was so great.
I mean, in a way it's parallel --
maybe this is why the
book is so personal
because it's not the same degree
of achievement in any way.
But it's parallel to what Sam said.
The first thing I wrote
for Boston After Dark,
all the original things I wrote
and were talking about payment,
which is never worth thinking about.
But I don't get -- I didn't get
paid anything for years and years.
I mean, I wrote about --
the first thing I wrote
about was the James Brown Show.
And I wrote about it.
This was a time of
happenings in theater.
I said, "This is the
greatest, spontaneous eruption.
This is the greatest
improvisational theater.
happening you'll ever see,"
and described what I had seen
from going to James Brown,
to the James Brown show
over the last few years.
And just was trying to sell
people on the idea of going
to see James Brown because
it would uplift them.
It would elevate them.
It would give them
a vision of Nirvana.
And not psychedelic, psychedelia.
But so and that was
why I wrote them.
I wrote about Muddy Waters.
It was a thrill to me to put
down -- set down their names.
I never thought of it as a vocation.
I don't even know if I thought
of it was an advocation.
It was just -- it was a mission
to sort of tell people --
it was a thrill to
put the names down,
to write the name Big Joe Turner,
to type it out, to see it in print,
to write about Johnny Shines, to
write about Bo Diddley and to try
to present them in terms that
did justice to the greatness
of their achievement,
not to play off of --
not to say it was awesome
or not to say --
but to try to describe
what it was that was
so elevated about what they did.
And not to do it in -- I'm sure
to some people it may still
seem very pretentious,
but it was to do it in terms
that were attempted to be equal
and treat the music with the dignity
that it deserved and
also the enthusiasm.
So that was my entire motivation.
It remains my entire motivation.
I mean, I wrote -- I
considered myself --
I never considered myself a critic.
I've always thought of myself
as an advocate in a sense.
I've never written about
anything that I didn't love.
I've never written on assignment.
And I'm not saying that boastfully.
I mean, it was really hard to do.
It caused -- as my son, Jake,
said when he was about 8 years old
and starving from lack of food.
I was never starving
from lack of food
but I often thought we could
have better food on the table.
But the thing was it was something
I felt absolutely committed to,
and that's really as much
as anything the motivation
for the Sam Phillips is to tell
the world as [inaudible] said,
"Tell the world about Sam Phillips."
Or he said, "Tell the
world about what?"
It's whatever the song is.
>> Geoffrey Himes: All right.
Do we have microphones for people?
Anybody have questions?
Maybe Ann can help identify people.
>> [Inaudible] Q and A
and afterwards we'll explain
about the book selling.
We won't be selling books tonight,
but we will be offering ten
percent off in our bookshop,
and we'll explain how that goes,
but let's go ahead with Q and A.
>> Peter Guralnick: Let me
also say that if you do want
to have it signed, but
if you brought a book,
I'm glad to sign that.
This is not a silent
auction or anything
so if you have something you want
to say and get -- that's fine --
or ask or something like that.
So it's -- I'm sorry to hear about
the books, the lack of books.
But anyway, any books you
brought that you want me
to sign, I'm glad to sign.
>> Having looked at your website
and picture after photograph
after photograph and a few
minutes ago you made the --
said the phrase people I've met,
and I'm assuming you've met a lot
of people and interviewed
a lot of people.
But does one or two real son
of a bitches come to mind?
>> Peter Guralnick: No, no.
I mean -- because the
point is what have I done?
I've gone out looking for
people that I've admired.
I mean, it's -- if you ask me if
I admire everything about them?
No. I mean, who am I
to make the judgment?
I'm interested in somebody -- like
Merle Haggard for example is not --
he's whatever you call it, like a
sweet cup of tea on every occasion.
But it's not -- I don't
feel any investment
in somebody being one
way or another.
I admire the hell out
of Merle Haggard.
I just see him as one of
the great creative artists
of the 20th century.
And that -- or maybe any century.
And that's what I'm writing about.
What I'm interested in talking to
people about is what motivates them,
what their ambition is,
what their aspirations are,
what their aspirations were and
describing what the weather was.
I don't have any particular
pride or place in this.
I don't see myself as
either being insultable
or threatenable in a sense.
So no, I would say not.
>> Geoffrey Himes:
Follow up that question.
It seems that one of the
challenges for a biographer is how
to balance the work with
the life and most --
a lot of biographies write about the
drugs and marriages and so forth,
which is not why we're interested
in them in the first place.
And I was wondering how you wrestled
with that problem or that challenge?
>> Peter Guralnick: I
feel like I think we --
I'm going to recapitulate some of
what we talked about at dinner,
but I feel as if I've got
a number of commitments.
The first commitment is
to telling the truth.
The second commitment to being fair
to the person I'm writing about,
treating anybody I write
about with dignity and respect
that I would hope for
and that they deserve.
It's kind of the opposite
of some political figures
in this particular age.
And I guess the third thing is
just being true to the reader.
So it's not like I feel
like I can leave things out.
It's not that I have a
view of them particularly.
I mean, if somebody leads -- for
instance, I've been with people
when I was doing portraits.
I've been with people where I
saw things happen that I felt --
while I was accidentally
witnessed to them, I had no right
to expose them whatever the
[inaudible] might have been.
They informed the way in which I
saw the person I was writing about,
not necessarily negatively.
I mean, I just don't
have a judgment.
I don't have -- I'm not
bringing my values to bear
on the person I'm writing about.
But they certainly could inform but
it wasn't like I was going to break
up a marriage or put somebody in
jail because I happen to be present
at something that I was
an accidental observer.
But I mean, we talked a little.
I mean, I wrote about Charlie
Rich in Feel Like Going Home,
the first book I wrote,
which actually all
of the books were written
as books as opposed to --
that was something where I
went out and wrote the book
as individual portraits, but they
were all written for the book.
Lost Highway was the
one exception to that.
But the thing was, I meet
Charlie Rich out at the Vapors
out by the airport in Memphis.
It later became either Big Bad Bob's
Vapors or just Bad Bob's Vapors.
I don't know if it's
still in operation or not
but it was fairly --
until fairly recently.
And I met him at a tea
dance where there --
he and Narvel Felts and
Ace Cannon alternated sets,
and I think there must have been
at lease nine sets among them.
It went on for a long time.
Meeting Charlie Rich and his wife
Margaret Anne, I don't think I've --
I don't think I've ever liked
anybody better on first meeting.
When I came to writing about
him, I thought this is terrible.
I'm never going to get to see him
again, this guy that I like so much,
Margaret Anne who I like so much,
because the portrait that I drew.
And you'll laugh if you read
the book, if you read Feel
Like Going Home because it seems
so pale in light of the way
in which peole are
written about today.
But I thought I'm never going to
see him again because I was writing
about depression, guilt, alcoholism,
just a sense of exclusion
and insecurity and agoraphobia
which was very odd for a performer.
And -- but it was what I
had to write, and I wrote it
from as I feel one is compelled to.
You write it from an
empathetic point of view.
An actor can't portray a
villain and you can't --
and just go [inaudible] every other
word just to show his distance
or her distance from the
character she's portraying.
But so I wrote this, and I just
felt badly, but that was the truth.
And I tried to treat it with
honesty, with dignity, with respect.
But that was the truth.
And I've never been more
relieved or never felt better
than when the publisher
of Feel Like Going Home,
the woman named Margaret Pete called
me up and said, "I had to tell you.
I just got a call from Charlie Rich,
and he ordered 30 copies of the book
to give to all the
members of his family."
And when I saw him not longer
afterwards, and I was friendly
with him until he died
for the next 25 years.
But when I saw him, he said, "You
know, the truth hurts sometimes,
but it's the truth, and
you wrote the truth."
Not everybody takes that
view, but that's what I --
and I'll tell you a round about
story, a quick round about story,
but a magazine wanted to
do an excerpt first serial
from [inaudible], a big magazine.
It would have been a great thing.
But what they wanted me
to do was to rewrite --
it was the part about Larry Geller
who was Elvis' sort
of spiritual advisor.
Adventures in new age religion,
and that's what he was.
That was what he was interested in.
That's what Elvis was interested in.
It's not what I'm interested in.
I mean, I may be disappointing you
here, but this is not my interest.
I'm not a [inaudible].
I'm not a follower
of Madame Blavatsky
or Audiobiography of a Yogi.
But that's what they
were interested in.
And so this magazine wanted
me to portray Larry Geller
as a hippocrite and a charlatan.
Now, it's possible.
I'm not saying it's
true, but it's possible
that that might be my personal view.
As I say, I'm not saying that
it is, but it's possible.
But I would never portray him.
His role in Elvis' life
was a legitimate role.
He had a genuine knowledge
and interest,
knowledge of an interest
in those areas.
Elvis was passionate about them.
He devoted 2.5 years
of his life to it.
And it ended very unhappily
because they dropped the excerpt,
and I felt like I poisoned
the relationship with somebody
who could be very important.
And I'm not saying
this to be heroic.
I'm just saying I felt an obligation
both to the truth and to try
to understand what it was
with the people I was writing
about were not what
I thought of them
or what it provided
judgment of them.
>> So today a young Elvis
Presley instead of going
to a studio would probably
record a demo
in his home on his own equipment.
And so I wondered what
your thoughts might be
as to what we might have
lost through this process
and are there any up sides to it
that we don't have
necessarily people
like Sam Phillips taking
people under their wing?
>> Peter Guralnick:
I'm not sure how many
up sides there are to the internet.
I know it's a huge convenience.
But I think we're moving the filter
and also we're moving the idea
that I told you I don't
believe there's any such thing
as objectivity, but I do
believe there's such a thing
as editorial weighing
or at least some attempt
at the appearance of objectivity.
And I think the collaboration
to go back to what Geoffrey said
to begin with, the collaboration
of two people, the collaboration
of Sam Phillips and Howlin' Wolf
or Sam Phillips and Elvis Presley
or Chips Moman and Elvis
at the American sessions
in '69 can create a -- or even
the creation of the collaboration
of something like Elvis Costello and
Allen Toussaint on River in Reverse.
Is it called River in Reverse or
was that the -- that's the single?
What was the album called?
That was it?
Okay. Anyway, I think this can
lead to all kinds of things.
I think creating -- on the other
hand, creating on your own --
not everybody needs
that collaboration.
Not everybody needs leadership.
The problem is we've lost any
sense of common heritage I guess.
I mean, I know from teaching
at Vanderbilt there is
not a single book that is
in a creative writing course --
there's not a single
book that everyone
in the class has read except
To Kill a Mockingbird.
And maybe The Great Gatsby.
Other then that, it's not that
people don't read, but there is --
and so the conversation is
abbreviated to some extent.
I mean, I'm interested, and I try
to engage in this conversation by --
I try to find out from everyone.
I say what are you into?
Movies, books, music.
But there's almost no common ground
and certainly no shared heritage.
And I think what you lose by that
is the ability to build on that.
Elvis was totally conscious
of being part of a tradition,
of being part of this
continuum of great music
that included Howlin' Wolf,
Hank Williams, Carusso,
included Carusso, included
all of this.
And today our sense of history
might go back five years
but not any longer and maybe not
even five years at this point.
So I think that is
a lot lost in that.
At the same time, there are
tremendous opportunities,
and the creativity.
There's no less creativity today.
There are no fewer original voices.
There's no absence of music,
art, literature to celebrate.
I mean, people talk about
the death of the novel.
I think there are more great novels
being written now then ever before.
It's harder to find
them on common ground.
But I don't think anything will ever
discourage Sam Phillips [inaudible].
If you are a creative person, for
God's sake, don't let anything get
in the way of that creativity.
I think for the creative
person nothing will get
in the way of that creativity.
>> Thank you, Peter.
Two questions.
First of all, the people
that you've written
about are pretty much originals.
But as you said, it's
continuum of music.
So my first question is
are there any artists --
you mentioned Elvis Costello as
an artist with [inaudible] --
that you would like
to write about today?
That you think either
having the same impact
and if so, who are they and why?
If not, why not?
And the other question
is music is passed down.
You mentioned your son
who criticized the meals
on your table for a time.
>> Peter Guralnick: No, no, no.
He was just -- I like
the combination
of I'm starving for lack of food.
I thought that was --
>> But I was saying were you able to
take this great love that you have
for it and influence him at
all in terms of his music?
That's something fathers
think about.
You pass it down.
You either accept it or reject it.
So both of those if you would.
>> Peter Guralnick: Well, I
think as far as passing down,
I mean Jake manages groups.
My daughter, Nina, has been
involved in various ways
in the music business and others.
Now she's the head of the Children's
International Film Festival.
But no, I wouldn't want to
pass on my taste particularly.
We share common enthusiasms,
but I'm as interested
in their sharing what they're into
with me as my sharing it with them.
I think it's the idea of pursuing
what Sam called individualism
in the extreme.
That to me was the idea of relying
on your resourcefulness as opposed
to looking for a path which took
you step by step through life
or made you fearful
of taking gambles.
I mean, in many ways I
think I would aspire to --
or Jake and Nina represent is what
I aspire to be when I grow up.
But I don't -- we certainly
share a lot in common.
I remember taking Nina
against her vociferous will
to go see I.F. Stone towards the end
of his life after he learned Greek
and he was talking about --
was he talking about the
trials of Socrates trial?
And Nina's looking around
saying, "KQ is zero."
KQ being kid quotient.
"Why do I have to be here?"
And I said, "Because greatness
such as this will not
pass your way again."
But I didn't expect to sell her
on I.F. Stone, and I didn't.
But I wanted at least to expose her.
I took Jake -- I took him to see
Aretha Franklin when he was 2 or 3,
and he met Muddy Waters
when he was 7 or 8.
But I don't see that as significant.
It was -- what was significant was
exposing him to the possibility,
the possibilities of art, the
possibility of creativity,
the breadth, the breadth of
choices that are available.
And so I think that was
it more than anything.
>> So I have a -- when you were
speaking earlier about your sense
of yourself as an evangelist for
the music that you really enjoy,
as you've written books and you've
traveled and spoken about the music
that you enjoy, I'm wondering if
you had a sense of whether or not
that the audience for what
you're saying is different here
than it is in Europe.
As a fan of this music,
for instance,
I've noticed that there are
ridiculously lavish treatments
of for instance the Sun Catalog
from Bear Family in Germany.
There's nothing like that in
the U.S. I listen to a lot
of [inaudible] blues, and there's
document records in England and JSP,
and there's nothing
really like that here.
And I'm wondering --
>> Peter Guralnick: What
about the [inaudible]?
>> But [inaudible] -- okay --
>> Peter Guralnick:
[Inaudible] has stopped in that,
but for the first 20
or 30 years or so.
>> Maybe this is a
misperception on my part.
But it seems like there's more
in terms of getting the music
out there, there seems like there's
more enthusiasm about it there
than there is here, and I was just
wondering if you perceived anything
like that when you've talked
to people about the music?
>> Peter Guralnick: I think
that Richard Weize I think
recently sold Bear Family
but who has owned Bear
Family from the beginning.
He is one of a kind.
And his dedication essentially
to creating a library
of American music -- not just
American, but that's what I know,
and his documentation of
Sun and his willingness
to just expand the most
lavish amounts of time.
I don't know about
money, but certainly time
and probably money too, is unique.
I don't think it has to
do with him being German.
It just has to do -- or European,
it has to do with just somebody
who is so driven to do this.
And I wrote in the brief discography
at the back of Sam Phillips
that really for the
first time in all the --
writing about the music that I could
send people to a single catalog,
to the Bear Family catalog.
Not that that not necessarily
is going to be everything
that they would want, but it's
just an astonishing achievement.
A lot of the other stuff
-- I mean, some of it --
we're a very big country
and for something to be hip
in England doesn't necessarily
represent a huge amount of people
to have the Sweet Soul Music
Festival in [inaudible] which I went
to for years which is phenomenal.
It doesn't mean that
soul music is prevalent
in Italy as opposed to here.
It's probably popular here,
but it's more dispersed.
And I think there's a
trendiness to some of it.
As Sam said, for God's sake,
that's the one thing we don't need.
We don't need another trend.
Whatever the trend is.
Even if it's something you like.
But no, I think there's always
been a real appreciation of music.
I think the other thing to keep
in mind is the copyright laws.
And so much of what's
put out in Europe.
Our copyright laws are
dictated by Disney.
I mean, that's what has
extended what was supposed
to go to public domain.
But the European copyright
laws actually sanctioned theft
in many ways.
And Bear Family, for example, will
put together incredible 12 CD set
and then have it bootlegged by
three or four English labels
for say newly remastered.
But it's all they've done
is they've taken the --
and Bear Family tried
to mark their masterings
so that they would be detectable,
but it cost too much money to sue.
So I think there is to
some degree what you say,
but labels like [inaudible] before
that [inaudible] library
were amazing collections.
What Roots did was essentially
to do every single record,
and it's invaluable if you want
to have every single record
by Tamper Red or by Frankie
Half Pint Jackson or something.
But it's not -- I don't know.
I'm not going to knock it,
but I would say there
has been a great deal
of appreciation here as well.
It takes different forms
in different places.
>> Peter, any Prisonaire
stories you can share with us?
>> Peter Guralnick:
I always liked --
and the Prisonaires were this
group that was brought to Sam
by his sometime partner, Jim
Bullet, who had had the Bullet label
in Nashville which had one of
the greatest hits of all time
in Francis Craig's
Near You in the 40's.
Something which I doubt that many of
you heard, and I wouldn't have heard
if I weren't writing the book.
But anyway, Jim Bullet brought
the Prisonaires who were part
of the Frank Clemmons, Governor
Frank Clemmons, who was a great --
Sam greatly admired as a true
Democrat, big D, little D,
which Sam always considered
himself and a great believer
in rehabilitation prisons in prison.
And Prisonaires had been appearing
on a number of radio shows
in Nashville, had made
some [inaudible]
and so that's how Sam heard them.
Sam said, "Then the
devastation came over me."
That's the quote I always liked.
Sometimes I'll remember
the word devastation.
Sometimes I don't.
Because it was both the music
which was very much derived
from the Ink Spots
which was really --
Bill Kenny, an idol of Elvis'
as well as the lead singer
for the Prisonaires,
but Johnny Brag.
But it was also the idea of
doing something, of being a kind
of Clarence Darrell, doing something
that could lead to rehabilitation.
And he went over.
He went over to Nashville to
meet with Frank Clemmons to try
to pursuade him not to allow
Sam to record them in prison,
which he could have easily done,
but to allow them to be transported
with guard and trustee to
the Sun Studio in Memphis.
Memphis Recording Service
in Memphis.
And he brought with him a gospel
singer named Howard Surat [assumed
spelling] who Sam often said had the
most beautiful voice he ever heard.
Again, Sam had [inaudible]
for everyone.
That was his [inaudible].
But he is a beautiful singer,
and Sam tried very half-heartedly
to get him to sing pop.
And I think was very relieved
when Howard Surat had no interest.
Well, he was convinced
that if Frank Clemmons
who was also an Evangelical -- if
he heard Howard Surat and listened
to Sam's arguments that he would
agree and Howard Surat brought
with him a guy whose
name was otherwise lost
to history as far as I know.
Reverend something
like [inaudible] Ray
who was an evangelist
from maybe Nebraska.
I've known at some point
and who Howard Surat was
going around singing for.
It was like on the
Billy Graham Crusade.
So there's a picture of all of
them when Sam made his pitch,
and Frank Clemmons was
pursuaded and that's how Sam set
out the first Prisonaires
session which was then a reporter
from either Commercial Appeal,
Press Scimatar was present at,
wrote the article and that's
what brought Elvis in.
>> Thank you.
>> I think we maybe just have
time for one question more
and then we'll set up
in the hallway there.
>> Great hearing you again tonight.
Getting back to Solomon
Berg, it would be great
if you could do that book.
I know Solomon performed a
couple times, and he's awesome.
Started listening to him
about 40, 50 years ago.
But did he not have 12 children?
Maybe 20? Which a number
of them ended
up in his band performing
with him for many years?
Could not these kids be
great sources for information
about Solomon Berg for a really
terrific definitive book?
>> Peter Guralnick: Well,
information doesn't even begin
to approach the book that should
be written about Solomon Berg.
And I never wanted to do anything
but a book in Solomon's voice.
So he did -- I can't
remember at this point.
How many children did he have?
He had 12?
How many was it?
I thought it was like
21, but as Solomon said,
I got lost in the Bible verse
that said go forth and multiply.
But he -- and his last
four children by --
with his wife Sunday [assumed
spelling] Ho, and he said to me,
"You know, ho ho noodles."
As if I would know.
Do all of you know
about ho ho noodles?
To this day, I don't.
Sunday was very charming,
very nice person.
I never asked her about
the noodle company.
But his last four children
[inaudible] and Queen Elizabeth.
I'm trying to remember who else.
Candy. I don't know
who she was named for.
They did perform with him as
did one of his sons, Junior.
JFK Junior.
And I think there was one other.
And his brother, Ellik
[assumed spelling]
when I first met Solomon
was playing guitar for him.
But nobody could tell
Solomon's story but Solomon,
like Solomon or but Solomon.
The thing about Solomon was that
like Sam he was a creative artist
of the highest attainment,
not just when he was singing
in every aspect of his life.
And there was no story he told no
matter how fanciful it might seem
that didn't have some basis in
reality like the time he played
for the Ku Klux Klan by mistake.
He says and they're
coming towards me.
These lights, these torches.
They're all wearing hoods.
Little children wearing
little hoods.
But every one of these stories
had some basis in reality,
and often I confronted
that reality but they were
so beautifully comically
and brilliantly told.
The popcorn story or the -- no, the
only way we lost our opportunity
to write the book, Solomon
and I when Solomon died.
>> Anne McLean: I hate to cut
this off because it's so warm
to see how you guys have
been entrancing everybody.
Thank you so much.
Let's thank them rather very warmly.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.